et leurs invités ce soir leurs plus
belles scènes où malgré ça ça demande
l'aide de dieu ne ne vient pas alors
c'est vrai on s'attendait un peu à vous
trouver dans le rôle d'un prêtre a
encore moins je dirais dans le rôle d'un
prêtre homosexuel vous en sortez très
bien je viens donc l'été 2003 faisait
déjà eu beaucoup de succès avec un été
de canicule avec charlotte de turckheim
et puis l'été qui vient vous allez
tourner toujours pour france 2 l'homme
pressé de paul morand de paul morand
voilà qu'elle était incarnée par votre
père au cinéma en 1976 77 edouard
molinaro edouard molinaro
alors vous disiez récemment qu'on a
tendance à oublier les 85 films les
quatre chef-d'oeuvre de votre père pour
toujours parler du du du champagne du
parfum etc
et ça vous énerve ça ça m'énerve vrai on
peut parler du champagne et du reste
mais il faut parler aussi des
chefs-d'oeuvre qui font partie sa
filmographie est important quoi
aujourd'hui je pense que un homme comme
mon père comme jean-paul font vraiment
partie du patrimoine français et ça doit
se respecter
anthony delon on va faire une interview
papa l'a fait